what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
oh my goodness rob cor I woke up this
morning I had a leisurely breakfast of
steak and eggs
I was watching World War Z the book is
still better than the movie and we are
getting ready to cover rage of the Red
Lanterns so this story is amazing oh my
god this is so good because this is like
I think it's this and then it's Agent
Orange which is largely z' and then we
go into blackest night so we've got like
two weeks until we start blackest night
which I'm really kind of hyped about
because that story is insanely good but
for those of you guys who are just now
getting caught up with us here on our
Green Lantern Sundays I guess is what it
is
the Green Lantern landscape so far has
basically dealt with Sinestro Corps war
which is to say the villain fell
Sinestro a former Green Lantern who
basically became corrupted by his power
falling and then forming his own yellow
Lantern Corps this really led into a
series of paradigm shifts where the
Green Lantern's were always more of a
peacekeeping force because of the
violence of Sinestro because his reins
were not limited by the ability to kill
like the Green Lantern rings were they
couldn't actually kill people the
guardians of the universe the creators
of the Green Lantern Corps basically
modified the rules of the Rings so that
Green Lantern's could now kill people
and this was the ultimate goal of all
Sinestro was to basically turn the Green
Lantern's or at least begin the process
of taking the universes I how they
perceived the Green Lantern's and move
it away from seeing the Green Lantern's
as protectors to seeing the Green
Lantern's as really more of like a
police force like this sort of army you
know belonging to these all-powerful
beings
I would lead people down the path of
coming to believe that the Green
Lantern's were effectively paving the
way for the guardians of the universe to
take over the universe that's not what
was actually happening all that fails
Sinestro needed was the belief that
that's what was going to happen now what
this does is it shifts over to the Red
Lanterns - Atrocitus now Atrocitus is a
character that we haven't really talked
about so it's recovered their secret
origin story of how Jordan the Green
Lantern but Atrocitus was formerly a
guide and I think as they was at Rose it
was formerly just a guy residing in
Sector six six six just one of the many
sectors that exists all throughout the
universe when it comes to DC Comics the
universe is divided into sections into
sectors so think of the universe or
think of the sectors of the universe is
like neighborhoods more or less is the
best way to think of it but the idea
here is that when the guardians of the
universe before they
created the Green Lanterns they had what
were called the Manhunters the idea was
that if there was going to be a
peacekeeping force around the universe
then the best way to do that was to use
robots because robots were only governed
by their programming they want governed
by emotion they weren't governed by fear
rage anger wrath any of those things
now this eventually led to the
programming of the Manhunters going awry
and one of the first casualties of their
screwed up programming was Sector 666
and at its time the family of Atrocitus
was basically destroyed in the conflict
now the reason why this matters is
because what happened following this is
Atrocitus was just set by absolute pure
rage now as we know rage is one of the
aspects of the emotional spectrum
remember when it comes to the whole
Green Lantern mythos the blue lantern
rings of Hope the orange Lantern ring of
avarice or greed the yellow Lantern ring
of fear they're all tied into the
emotional spectrum so long as there's an
emotion of rage so long as somebody in
the universe is mad as hell there will
always be a source of energy for the red
lanterns and so because of this a lot of
what this early story really does is
just kind of flesh out the nature of
Atrocitus forming his own Red Lantern
Corps now again all that's really
required in order for a person to be
able to form a Corps is to tap into the
emotional spectrum but it's easier said
than done
it really just requires somebody to be
so angry that it basically encompasses
their heart they become the living
embodiment of rage when that happens
it's almost like going super saiyan for
the first time in Dragonball right like
you just kind of manifest these new
powers and abilities with with the Green
Lantern's they just suddenly pop out a
power battery and they're able to tap
into this emotional spectrum now again
what this does is it leads to Atrocitus
becoming the first of the Red Lanterns
now the other half of this is again this
continued fallout of Sinestro Corps war
and again we cover that we talked about
that during the Sinestro Corps war
proper we said that that story was going
to lay the groundwork for a lot of
things that came after and there were
going to be a lot of threads coming out
of that that we're going to continue on
one of the things that takes place here
and really one of the the major threads
that leads directly into blackest night
is what it was that happen to the
anti-monitor the anti-monitor is
basically the harbinger of the death of
the multiverse you know whenever the
multiverse comes into existence you know
it died during crisis on Infinite Earths
it came back during Infinite Crisis
whenever the multiverse exists the
anti-monitor will always manifest with
it because the anti-monitor is
the living embodiment of the death of
the multiverse is the best way to
describe it the result of this is that
the anti-monitor allied itself with the
Sinestro Corps now at the end of
Sinestro Corps war the 80 monitor was
more or less defeated and just kind of
shot out into space but what we ended up
finding out is that some unknown being I
basically grabbed an C monitor and
turned him into a central power battery
what this also does is it brings into
sharp relief the idea of the scarred
guardian now I don't think the scarred
guardian actually has a name all we
really know is that this is one of the
guardians of the universe that is
basically grabbed one of the Green
Lantern's by the name of ash and sent
him on a mission of finding out what
happened to the anti-monitor and this is
inevitably going to pave the way for the
introduction of blackest night but at
this point information is just scant I
mean it's it's so scarce we'll get a
little bit more into what the prophecy
of the blackest night means as we get
through this but what is up happening
here is the Green Lantern's Hal Jordan
Guy Gardner Jon Stewart they're tasked
with basically escorting thousand estro
to his execution Green Lantern's don't
necessarily execute one of their own if
they like abuse their power but with all
Sinestro is a whole different beast
because not only he abuses power and
find himself booted out of the Green
Lantern Corps he in turn formed his own
Lantern Corps and then tried to kill
Green Lantern's and so he's basically
considered guilty of high treason
against the guardians of the universe
and the lanterns and so because of this
what ends up happening is that in the
midst of him basically being taken to
his imminent execution the most logical
scenario unfolds what we end up having
the Sinestro Corps really just kind of
pop out of nowhere for the purpose of
attacking the Green Lantern's now again
all this seems to be the workings of the
scarred guardian behind the scene the
scarred Guardian was the one who
informed the various members of the
Sinestro Corps the ones who were left
that thou Sinestro is being escorted to
his destination to Kruger the scarred
guardian is the one that basically
passed all this information on so that
the Sinestro Corps would know exactly
where to hit up but the caveat to this
is that in the midst so the Green
Lantern's escorting Thal Sinestro and
being ambushed by the Sinestro force
they're met with the unexpected arrival
of the Red Lantern so now again the
reason why Atrocitus is really chasing
after Sinestro the reason why he harbors
such hatred for him is because of the
fact that during the secret origin story
that we had talked about the one you'll
find down in the description alongside
all the other Green Lantern videos in
the playlist all Sinestro
the guy who basically defeated Atrocitus
that when Atrocitus had really just kind
of popped up for one of the first times
the result was that once the transfers
was taken back and dropped on the planet
of Bismol he basically made a prophecy
that a time would come when Thal
Sinestro's home planet of kuru dirt
would descend into chaos and madness and
in an attempt to control it Thal
sinestro would basically become a
dictator he would effectively cast aside
the role of the Green Lantern and
essentially become a villain and that's
exactly what happened now remember the
reason why this happens is because the
five inversions who are the five
survivors of the assault on Sector six
six six by the Manhunters alongside
Atrocitus they had the ability to cast
spells to delve into sorcery different
things like that that would let them see
the future and so what ended up
happening is when the five inversions
looked into the future they saw what
Sinestro would become the events that
would lead him to this very moment now
Dallas and Esther initially avoided it
just to know that's not going to happen
I'm not worried about that but
ultimately it all proved itself to be
true the crazy thing about this is that
when it comes to the various lanterns
and how they interact with one another
different lanterns have different
effects on other Lantern cores for
example what we end up having here is
the red lanterns who basically just
begin burning away the power of every
single Lantern that they come across the
Green Lantern ring of Hal Jordan begins
to become corrupted and what happens is
he suddenly met by the arrival of a guy
he's never seen before named Saint
Walker who claims to be a Blue Lantern
now here's a crazy thing I do not
understand why it is that that Green
Lantern fans love save Walker the
closest thing I can get to it the only
explanation I can come up with is the
blue lanterns are basically like the
Jedi of the DC Universe that's really it
they're just kind of like monks and
they're like all will be well I mean
it's one of those days it's one of those
weird things but this is what I'm
talking about when I say Wendy's can
compliment others the Blue Lantern rings
have the ability to basically recharge
Green Lantern rings and even supercharge
them so again having a Blue Lantern in
your corner
basically bolsters the powers of a Green
Lantern now there are also other aspects
of the blue lanterns but in terms of
where they come from in terms of how
they got here what we know is that in
the aftermath of the Sinestro Corps war
we basically had this prophecy of
blackest night now the prophecy of
blackest night again was another vision
from the five inversions they had looked
into the future and they had seen
there's going to be this massive
more of light but basically what's going
to happen is that all the different
Lantern cores are going to fight one
another the entire emotional spectrum is
basically going to be obliterated all
life in existence is going to vanish and
it'll be nothing but blackness the
blackest night is quite literally what
it sounds like now the idea is that the
guardians of the universe were warned by
Adam sors a predecessor to Hal Jordan
the guy who crash-landed on earth told
his ring to go find a replacement which
chose Hal Jordan that guy a dancer had
been told of the prophecy of blackest
night by Atrocitus Ivan sword had
reported its findings so the guardians
of the universe and they chose to ignore
it
what is up happening in the significance
of the Sinestro Corps war is it brought
into sharp relief other Lantern cores
are starting to pop up the zamarons
the women are I guess the different
aspects of the guardians of the universe
who used to be Malthusians or women or
whatever who broke off and began tapping
into the love aspect of the emotional
spectrum they have their own core now we
have the Red Lanterns we have a Sinestro
Corps all we're missing now are the
white Lantern's the black Lantern's we
haven't gotten to the orange lanterns
yet we have all these different Lantern
course popping up and when the guardians
of the universe began to realize what
was going on a majority of them ignored
everything that was happening they said
no the prophecy of the blackest night is
a myth it's not going to happen we don't
need to worry about that but a couple of
them ganthet and sayd believed that it
was true and so because of this ganthet
and sayd basically took the steps in
saying we need to make sure that if the
prophecy of blackest night is true that
were prepared for it's better to be
prepared for something that won't happen
and to not be prepared for something
that will happen and so because of that
what they ended up doing is forming
their own Lantern Corps the blue
lanterns now in terms of how this
courthouse core functions and how this
core exists this actually comes by way
of saint walker himself and what he ends
up doing is taking Hal Jordan to a
planet called Odom at least I think it's
called Odom their how it's pronounced
but what we end up finding out is that
with the Green Lantern cores are like
the Red Lantern Corps even the Sinestro
Corps something like that you're
basically like the Reiser just kind of
sent out into the universe you know the
Rings will be made and we'll just be
like okay just go out of there and just
find a replacement a person will just be
bonded with the ring for whatever reason
either they instill great fear or they
have great rage in their heart for they
have the ability to overcome great fear
whatever the case may be and they'll
just kind of take off just be sent to
training and they'll become a member of
that court with regards to the blue
lanterns it's
not that way what happens here is that
they are far more strict when it comes
to inducting members into their group
the process takes days and weeks a
person is brought before the blue
lanterns and they're basically sent to
this massive ritual now the reason for
this is because of the fact that the
blue lanterns are largely considered to
be the most powerful Lantern Court now
this is before the emergence of the
white lanterns to be honest but with
regards to the blue lanterns at this
point in time they're considered to be
the most powerful because there's hope
now the blue lanterns in terms of what
they can do again can basically cleanse
a person of the Red Lantern rage and
we'll get to that while you know guess
why that happens here in a second but
the idea is that the blue lanterns are
really more of like a foundation the
only they have abilities and so on and
so forth but the blue lanterns can only
really use their power if they're in the
presence of like a Green Lantern so
everything has checks and balances and
that's the really cool thing about it
it's one of the reasons why the Green
Lantern mythos is so just kind of
intriguing and interesting is because a
ring is powerful against one type of
ring but not against another you know it
complements one of the lantern course
but not another there's always these
different checks and balances that go
into this whole thing now the other half
of this is that we also pick up with the
idea that really how Jordan is designed
to kind of be this Harbinger for the
blue lanterns the intention is to make
him their leader now this is not readily
made - Hal Jordan instead what we end up
doing is we end up grabbing st. Walker
and the newest introduction to the Green
Lantern Corps and they're designed to
basically go after and find Sinestro now
the reason for this is because of the
fact that Sinestro is largely considered
to be one of the the prominent members
or a significant person for the coming
war of light we don't necessarily know
why but the indication here is that of
all the people who need to live it has
to be solve Sinestro he has to survive
this whole thing and so again that's why
this is so intriguing is because we're
giving these little tidbits use a little
itty-bitty pieces of information about
characters and we're talking Fortin they
are but we're not explicitly told why
now again the reason why this is so
important and it's so cool is because
for Hal Jordans character he's been a
trainee of Thal Sinestro he's fought
alongside thousand Nestor of any spot
against south Sinestro their lives have
basically been intertwined for years and
years and years and years not only that
it's also this idea that once they land
on the actual home planet of the Red
Lanterns and once
just begins you know to get into your
cow Jordan just recollecting on these
moments the experiences the two of them
had previously the discussions they got
into and all these different things the
battles they've had in the conflict they
had even if it's only for a brief moment
Dowell Sinestro becomes a friend he's an
ally for a split second when he tells
how Jordan to watch out now force this
leads to the emergence of the Red
Lanterns who of course promptly capture
Hal Jordan it's really this idea that
they basically captured who people
largely considered to be the two
greatest Green Lantern's in existence
now of course this leads to the arrival
of the Sinestro Corps and again that's
why this is so cool is because this is
Geoff Johns and DC giving us a taste
he's like look right now in this story
we're going to have the blue entrance
and the Green Lanterns and the Sinestro
Corps battling the red lanterns and
that's just for imagine if we had all
seven or eight or how many quarters are
imagine if they were all fighting
against each other at the same time and
that's the cool thing is because in the
midst of all this with chaos and
pandemonium rioting supreme Saint Walker
they all just kind of pop up on the
scene and it's like all will be well
when the ring of how Jordan begins to
deplete the blue lanterns are there to
charge it and that I think is one of the
reasons why fans love the blue lantern
so much because of Lee lanterns are just
kind of like this cool dude just just
chill man chill dude we got this man
like it's just it's calm it's relaxation
because they are effectively monks now
one thing when it comes to the idea of
the Red Lanterns what a person is imbued
with a Red Lantern ring they're designed
to basically be mindless the reason for
this is because with Atrocitus being the
first red lantern he has full control of
his faculties you'll notice he's not
like any of the other red lantern
Atrocitus thinks he rationalizes he
strategizes he's got all this history he
taunts different things like that
the other red Lancers are just mindless
raging beasts because they're not
designed to be tactical they're not
designed to be reasonable to think
things through they're designed to be a
force of nature
they're designed to exist and then
Atrocitus says go attack those guys over
there and then the Red Lanterns just
show up an overwhelming force just
inflicting mass pandemonium and
casualties but when it comes to Hal
Jordan because of the fact of the former
Green Lantern lyra again we talk about
her in the last video because of the
fact that she basically been exiled from
the Green Lantern's she absolutely
despised the members
the Sinestro Corps had a massive amount
of Rage wanted to kill every last one
that she came across and was following
that given a Red Lantern ring a really
just kind of forced into having a Red
Lantern ring she is effectively killed
by Sinestro now the reason why this
matters is because this sends Hal Jordan
over the edge the idea was that he was
going to try to find a way to save Lyra
Lyra was exiled because of the fact that
she basically killed a member of the
Sinestro Corps who had killed the family
of one of her teammates that was really
yet she wasn't like a villain she wasn't
trying to conquer a world she was just
angry and hurting and dealing with it
the best way she knew how
the result was that she was suddenly
bonded with a Red Lantern ring for
Sinestro he's not killing her to spare
Hal Jordans life not by any standard of
measurement he's doing that because he
knows it'll get to Hal Jordan and
because of this Hal Jordan snaps twirl
iris ring takes off and says finding a
new sentient Hal Jordan goes absolutely
berserk and just loses it on Sinestro
literally beating the absolute hell out
of them and in this moment of rage and
this moment of just absolute rampage Hal
Jordan is imbued with a Red Lantern ring
and that's the craziest thing because
this is the worst case scenario really
for almost anybody I mean I would
imagine at the time that story's being
written this is the worst case because
imagine for example that Atrocitus
basically gave Hal Jordan the ability to
be a rational thinking being imagine he
gave him the ability to basically be a
guy who could think on his own
how Jordan would literally crush almost
every single Lantern court that he came
across this is as close as we get to the
return of parallax one other thing to
keep in mind when it comes to the Red
Lanterns is that when a person is made a
Red Lantern there's all kinds of things
that come along with it with regards to
like the Green Lantern's for example
let's just take the traditional Green
Lantern
alright let's say that you're sitting at
home one day and a Green Lantern rain
just pops up in front of you and it says
you member of the rock or of course your
rob4 ring can overcome the Green Lantern
ring but nonetheless it pops up in front
of you and it says you have the ability
to overcome great fear welcome to the
Green Lantern Corps you're just whisked
away for training but you can turn down
the ring you can say you know what I
want to be a member of the Green Lantern
Corps I'm a member of a better Corps
called a Rob Corps I don't want no Green
Lantern ring at least I hope you guys
don't abandon me for the
Lanterns anyway but you could turn the
ring down you can say you don't want to
be a Green Lantern and the rain will
simply say okay searching for for a
replacement sentient with the red
lanterns it doesn't work that way put on
the Green Lantern ring and you can take
it off and you have different abilities
and it's all tied gear will power your
ability to overcome fear it's pretty
straightforward when a Red Lantern ring
bonds itself to you it becomes you you
basically have your heart replaced your
blood as your place with plasma if you
go to take the Red Lantern ring off
you'll die because literally the source
of your ability to exist goes away it's
tantamount to having your heart ripped
out of your body that's exactly the way
it works and so because of this under
any normal circumstance a person bonded
with a Red Lantern ring is going to die
the reason why this is so cool and the
reason why this is so interesting is
because in this moment when Hal Jordan
is basically running over all these
different emotions this pain that he's
feeling this hatred that is feeling this
rage all the things that Sinestro has
done where's mine in this body are going
through all these physical changes in
response to being given or basically
being possessed by a Red Lantern ring
suddenly st. Walker and company simply
show up and say we have no idea what's
going to happen when we do this but
we're making you a member of the Blue
Lantern Corps and the reason why is
because again as part of these checks
and balances the strengths of Lantern
cores versus the weaknesses of other
Lantern Corps so on and so forth the
Blue Lantern ring basically begin the
process of cleansing the person who's
infected with a Red Lantern ring so it
basically is their way out is their
caveat now that makes sense because if
that didn't exist what we basically have
is the Red Lanterns just spreading
across the universe like a plague with
no way to stop them now the idea here is
that with Hal Jordan basically being
given this Blue Lantern ring that works
in conjunction with his Green Lantern
ring he's effectively a hybrid now it's
almost like he has the best of both
worlds which is kind of cool here
because this sets the groundwork for a
lot of things that we'll end up seeing
coming up next but in terms of getting
into this prelude of the whole feel
block it's night this whole scenario we
basically end up having thousand estro
escaping back to its home planet you
know getting to the antimatter universe
on the planet of cord recharging is
raining using the central power battery
going out grabbing those individuals who
were truly faithful to the Sinestro for
killing those individuals who are not
again this follows a multitude of groups
as we all end up getting into this idea
of the war of light
but one of the things that happens here
and one of the things is interesting is
we also end up hinting at the orange
light of a burst now the orange light of
avarice has not been discussed yet we
haven't really done anything about it
yet that would be the next video that we
do but the orange light of avarice is
basically the orange light of greed and
it belongs to a singular guy named
Larfleeze now in terms of why he lives
in the Vegas system in terms of why it
is the guardians of the universe have
always been hands-off we'll get into
that as we get into his own individual
story but in terms of like the star
sapphires for example Carol Farris the
girlfriend of Hal Jordan joining the
star sapphires this comes by way of the
fact that with Howard when basically
taking off from Earth with Carol Ferris
having continually rebuked him she now
has a change of heart she wants him back
she wants him there and because of that
when Hal Jordan is basically often
spaced and Carol Farris takes off to
clear her mind her emotions begin to get
the better of her she begins to feel sad
she begins to feel a loss of love
because of this this makes her a target
for the star sapphires and so like she
was originally in or at least way back
in the 1950s when she was a star
sapphire this is history repeating
itself all over again and so again
that's the basis behind this rage of the
Red Lantern story yes it deals with the
Red Lanterns but it's also this coming
together of all these different Lantern
cores because this is the last piece of
the puzzle until we get to blackest
night the whole story of orange lantern
of Larfleeze deals almost exclusively
with him there's some other things that
are thrown in there here and there but
this is basically the stepping stone in
the blackest line we can actually skip
Agent Orange and then just jump into
this and that would really be it we're
not going to but I'm but we could you
know we could just jump into blackest
night it would take a little bit away
from the story though but again I'm
pretty excited I'm pretty hyped because
we've got Agent Orange and then we've
got blackest slide what we might do next
week is we might double up we might do
Agent Orange and didn't start blackest
night I have no idea but if you guys are
new here to come this explain make sure
you I said the sub button to become part
of the Roth pork you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all in it peace
[Music]
but all I can see is the summer we spend
the matter my
the kids